bonjour ici c'est steve coleman
ça fait longtemps que je n'ai pas fait
une vidéo
il paraît qu'on dit un vidéo au québec
et une vidéo ailleurs parce que vidéo
c'est soit vidéogrammes ou vidéo
qu'est ce que j'ai vu vidéo
quelque chose là l'idéogramme ou bien
vidéographie donc selon que ce soit
vidéographie vidéogrammes c'est un essai
normalement c'est une ailleurs et c'est
un au québec
bon je dirais une vidéo parce qu'il me
semble que la plupart des gens la
plupart des gens disent à une vidéo
je vais parler de quelque chose de
plusieurs choses
d'abord je serai à montréal le 16 et le
17 septembre avec ma femme s'il ya des
personnes là qui veulent me rencontrer
ou rencontrer d'autres polyglotte toute
personne qui aime apprendre les langues
on pourrait essayer d'organiser un mythe
up soit le 16 ou le 17
un mémorial par la suite avec ma femme
ne seront à mont tremblant pour cinq
jours et après ça nous allons visiter la
france surtout la bretagne est un peu
voir en normandie
par la suite un champagne pour un jour 2
pour éviter paris parce que je connais
très bien paris mais je veux éviter
toute la circulation etc
et c'est surtout pour voir un très bon
ami qui à 97 ans qui habite là à bernard
notre très bon ami qui a reçu
le titre de chevalier de la légion
d'honneur
on veut aller le féliciter
bon ça c'est une chose qu'est ce qu'il y
avait ah oui deuxième chose en ce qui
concerne l'apprentissage des langues
j'avais fait une vidéo assez courtes sur
ce sujet en anglais donc je vais me
répéter ce que j'ai dit souvent quand on
a une tâche à compléter qui semble très
j'en heureux une tâche un tas ne fait
pas très certainement il suffit de
commencer fossiles
il suffit de faire un petit parc suffit
par exemple si pour angers selon bureau
là par exemple ou une pièce ou une
chambre à coucher ou n'importe quoi ben
si c'est vraiment une pagaille
il faut longer balle il faut commencer
par des petits pas rangé une chose et
une autre chose et voilà petit petit à
petit la tâche est compliquée et c'est
la même chose par exemple quand on était
à 1 je me rappelle quand j'étais à
l'université si on a des espèces de
projets à faire et il semblait y avait
beaucoup de travail telles choses que je
ne comprenais pas il suffisait de
commencer de faire des petites tranches
qu'on dit c'est comme tranché salami il
suffit de couper de tranchées de
tranchées de trancher et tout d'un coup
il n'y a plus de ya plus de saucisson
parce que fait des petites tranches même
des traces très mince et éventuellement
la tâche des fêtes
et c'est la même chose dans
l'apprentissage des langues par exemple
des fois je me dis ah ben je vais
rien faire aujourd'hui bien
qu'aujourd'hui j'ai faim j'ai écouté pas
mal la russie en ukrainien
mais je parle il eut alors là mais
maintenant je vais lire revenir un peu
sur mon ipad je veux dire des choses que
j'ai téléchargé de l'internet à
l'ukrainien et je sais que chaque transe
chaque petit range aussi mince qu'elle
soit
ça m'aide sa semaine à m'approcher à mon
but c'est à dire à mieux comprendre
faire croître à mon vocabulaire mieux
parler dont il faut toujours il faut pas
essayer de faire des grand bond en avant
il faut essayer toujours de faire des
pitres ans la main c'est petit à petit
la tnt
on va voir du progrès on va s'avancer
vers ces objectifs
voilà et c'est tout ce que j'ai à dire
et si vous avez envie de rencontrer des
des amateurs de l'apprentissage des
langues soit montréal soit en france
dites le moi et voilà et c'est tout au
revoir